l'agglo vous dit cette vidéo nos verres
il manque des choses c'est évident quand
on se promène dans les rues qui ont été
rénovés alors où quand on a le nez sur
le macadam
c'est une magnifique et c'est quand on
lève les yeux quand on regarde l'aspect
dégradé des appartements on s'aperçoit
que là il ya un véritable effort à faire
ballack où il faut que ces marées la mer
monsieur le maire sortant il faut le
faire en collaboration avec les autres
collectivités je pense en particulier au
conseil départemental dont je suis
membre et qui travaille activement sur
la rénovation des appartements
quand on veut travailler dans son coin
on s'isole savez c'est pas en chine à
las vegas à tel aviv ce corps elle aux
open entendu pas au ph est porté par
l'agglomération le département en vue de
la vente est rien on va vous exposer
leurs oeuvres